did you see the did you see the mark
zuckerberg presentation beta
you've seen that yeah no what do you
mean yes which part get off his nuts no
i'm just he's a villain
i know the matrix he's a bad guy the
matrix is here too he's a bad guy well
why are you saying that though i know i
okay i get it but it's like there's a
property you're watching facebook
crazy yeah all the data that came out of
it yeah how it's addicting and instagram
for kids and they knew it and then
doubled down on it what are we doing
pretty crazy look at it that's what a
bad guy that's he's the new villain
spider-man 4. there you go it is really
weird how much of a
he really does look like a villain yeah
you know he talks on you too oh it
always like look just this meta thing
every it's so funny ever since elon musk
came out all the guys want to be elon
musk they're like oh we need
personalities worth a trillion dollars
elon yeah but but but but him jeff bezos
like they were no they were not in front
of the camera until no they want to be
famous
they want right celebrity now right well
because elon musk is like the bruce
wayne of them and now there's these guys
that and and what's his name zuckerberg
is just like i i surf or whatever the
[ __ ] you know and you're just like okay
okay i i surf i surf that's it good
that's good yeah that's spot on i eat
meat i eat i eat meats and i surf i have
a cooker i have a cooker
i eat meats and i surf hey i like how
you change yeah holograms hey i like how
to change the name to meta yeah
because they're getting all this
backlash so they think by changing the
name people are just like okay
well then yeah the new technology they
have is very strange with vr but how
about the fact that you can't be a
[ __ ]
you can't be a company that's like
taking over the world and it'd still be
named facebook that's some bitch-ass
company name
meta is at least a it's a good name
do you know what matters
chris
chris
no
i think meta is a good name
chris this is even chris
oh [ __ ] he's got a short
ox
meta
have you seen the
logo
[Music]
it's an infinity sign
meta facebook is
no more
what do you have to say about facebook
being uh bad for young people's mental
health
just makes me laugh
the
data
i know the
data
fake news
fake news
fake news
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is so dangerous
metachris where is chris the real chris
[Music]
in the metaverse well
what did you do to him is he no longer
y'all
is he dead
he's so stupid
[ __ ]
yeah